well we begin in Sudan Where the wild
food program says one of its warehouses
has come under attack
armed men looted the facility containing
tens of thousands of tons of food and
supplements in alabay that's in South
Central Sudan it's one of the largest
logistic hubs of the United Nations
agency in Africa the wfp says it will
put more than 4 million people caught in
conflicts at risk well let's speak to
Heber Morgan she joins us now from
omduman that's across the River Nile
from Khartoum but let's start with what
we're hearing now from the wfp we have
heard that Aid agencies have been saying
that looting has been going on I mean
the situation was already dire
uh yes indeed now the Looting did not
start just two days ago with the world
food program but it started at the very
beginning of the conflict in mid-april
uh world food program warehouses in the
western part of the country in Dartford
were also looted in the capital of
warehouses belonging to the UN several
U.N agencies and their offices have been
looted as well that's affected the aid
operations here in the country now we're
talking about at least 80 000 metric
tons of food that have been looted since
the start of the conflict affecting more
than 4 million people as per the world's
food program most of them are located in
the dark four region where the fighting
has affected millions of people cutting
them from basic humanitarian assistance
and then there's those here in the
capital hartum with eight organizations
being looted with the warehouses being
affected and with no humanitarian
corridors opened millions of people
remain in the capital unable to access
humanitarian assistance and the little
that is coming through is not enough for
those who are in the capital waiting for
that Assistance or looking for ways to
leave the capital to safer zones where
they can find basic food commodities
heavy you're there on the ground now
despite all the Diplomatic efforts we've
been talking about for weeks now the
fighting has been continuing I see
Washington is now turning up the
pressure is that likely to make any kind
of difference
well first of all look at let's look at
let's take a look at the companies that
have been sanctioned the companies that
produce weapons ammunitions and vehicles
for both sides two of them Affiliated to
the rapid support forces and two of them
belonging to the Sudanese Army so it
looks like the United States is trying
to put pressure on these companies to
make sure that their normal weapons
procured there are no more vehicles
procured and therefore this conflict
does not last longer than it should now
it's not clear if this would have an
immediate impact on the ground it's
worth noting that it's a experts and
analysts think that both sides are
prepared for this conflicts a long time
ago especially the rapid support forces
which have been building their troops
over the past four years when it comes
to the Army you also have the Industrial
Systems and complexes which have been
set up during sanctions era here in
Sudan so it's not clear what immediate
impact this would have but the talks in
Jeddah that is supposed to bring a
ceasefire between the Sudan his Army and
the rapid support forces are currently
suspended because of repeated violations
so while yes efforts have been ongoing
to try to get the two sides to agree on
some sort of temporary ceasefire for
humanitarian Aid to come in the fact
that there's been numerous violations
and as per the mediators there's lack of
seriousness by both sides to actually
Implement any ceasefire fighting very
much continues on the ground with
civilians still remaining trapped in the
middle between the two wearing sides
Heather Morgan they're with all the
latest for us from omdemand on the
ground there in Sudan thank you Heba
well let's now bring in Ida El assaid
she is the Secretary General of the
Sudanese red crescent Society she joins
us now on the line from Port Sudan
either let me start by asking you how
your operations are going right now
given what we're hearing from other Aid
agencies about looting
we give him support for the people who
move from the Khartoum to Port Sudan to
find their way to
find the secure area students that
Garrison has provided them with food uh
where is it and mobile clinic and
psychological support for the people who
has been putting in a shelter area so
that we can support them the idps from
Khartoum and some people that from other
countries so I understand that Port
Sudan has been under curfew the state
government was speaking of rebellious
sleeper cells has that curfew impacted
your work there
the one day and completely the next day
we continue delivering the AIDS for uh
other other state in Sudan like it for
Khartoum and Jazeera and Northern State
where heavy population move there sure
given that we're hearing these reports
of looting from a number of other Aid
agencies are there concerns that any of
your supplies are being looted
especially as you try to move them
around the country
yes our main store in Khartoum and the
headquarter they all have been rooted
from the beginning of the war I'm very
sorry to hear that how are you dealing
with that especially within the context
of the security situation as well
obviously we've been hearing from our
correspondent fighting is ongoing
despite the fact that there was supposed
to be a truce how much hate are you
actually managing to get into the
capital
yeah
right now we're doing a paramedic with
the medical staff in the hospitals with
Distributing food jointly with wsp that
has been already implied for some and we
try to get more food through the River
Nile State distributed for the
vulnerable people there and we do
psychological support and we do the
burial of the dead body
it's obviously a very very busy time for
you you're at the moment in Port Sudan I
understand that has become obviously a
huge Aid Hub you were talking about
people huge amounts of people who are
still there is it very much still a
major evacuation route
there is some evacuation is being done
with the some Arabic country but still a
big number is still there and most of
the people who come there are people who
move from Khartoum and I
they don't think about going apart these
people they just run away from the war
in cartoon but there is some foreign
people there really want to cross the
border but they are they working in that
with the unhccr and with the
the government of this Edge so how are
they coping the people who have who've
tried to get out of cartoon are ending
up in Port Sudan is there the resources
to to deal with such huge crowds
actually if if they have all the paper
all the document and if there is a way
to evacuate them to their country it
will be done immediately as we see that
the people who have I witnessed that by
myself people who have a resident in
Qatar for example they have been
evacuated by the plan every three days
sorry I was actually asking about the
people the Sudanese people who are
coming from a cartoon just wondering
what kind of state they're arriving in
in Port Sudan
the people who arrive from Khartoum some
of them they stay with the families in
the houses some of them they rent houses
but some of them they still staying in
the shelter where we give distribute
food for them and water and we do the
mobile clinic as I said to you
I wanted to to let you go because I know
it's a very busy time for you thank you
so much for joining us here on Al
Jazeera Ida elside the Secretary General
of the Sudanese red crescent Society we
wish you all the best with your work Ida